[Musik]
thomas kemmerich will den thüringer
landtag auflösen das geht aber nur mit
einem antrag den mindestens 30
abgeordnete unterstützen
die fdp fraktion besteht nur aus fünf
abgeordneten kann den antrag also
alleine gar nicht stellen damit der
landtag tatsächlich aufgelöst wird
müssen 60 abgeordnete dafür sein ob
diese mehrheit zustande kommt ist
fraglich
nach einer auflösung gibt es innerhalb
von 70 tagen neuwahlen und kemmerich
wäre geschäftsführender
ministerpräsident bis eine neue
regierung steht da können schon mal
einige wochen oder gar monate vergehen
[Musik]
scheitert die auflösung des landtags
will kemmerich die vertrauensfrage
stellen entzieht ihm mehr als die hälfte
aller abgeordneten das vertrauen also
mindestens 46 kann das parlament einen
neuen ministerpräsidenten wählen
dafür sind drei wochen zeit gelingt das
nicht gibt es neuwahlen und kemmerich
bleibt im amt bis eine neue regierung
zusammentritt dann gibt es noch diese
möglichkeit eine landtagsfraktion stellt
ein konstruktives misstrauensvotum
gleichzeitig muss sie einen neuen
kandidaten für das amt des
ministerpräsidenten vorschlagen der dann
mehr als die hälfte aller stimmen
bekommen müsste fazit egal welches
szenario eintritt thomas kemmerich wird
offiziell noch einige zeit
ministerpräsident bleiben